-Welcome to the show.
They love you.
-Thank you so much.
Everyone's so lovely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww. It's a good crowd.
-Wow. Hi.
-I was asking you earlier if you
ever met Keanu Reeves before.
-Ah. The wonderful --
One time I have met him.
I was at an event,
and he was also there.
And we were kind of
the two introverts
on the outskirts of the party.
And we were just kind of
sitting there, like --
And then he said,
"Do you have a pet?"
And I said,
"I do. I have a dog."
And he went,
"Do you have any pictures
of your dog in costume?"
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting question.
-It was so sweet.
And I said, "I sure do."
-You actually had a photo...
-Oh, yes.
-...of your dog in a costume?
-Yeah.
-And you brought that photo
for us. Look at this.
-Yeah.
[ Audience awws ]
-[ Laughs ] Oh, come on.
Mouse.
-That's my sweet Mouse,
who's no longer with us.
-No longer with us.
Mouse, we love you, pal.
Making a debut
on "The Tonight Show."
-I know.
-Do you enjoy coming
to New York City?
Oh, I love it.
I love it so much.
-Do you have -- What are your
memories of this great city?
-The first time I ever came
here, I think I was 16,
and I was doing a press tour
for "Heavenly Creatures."
And Kate Winslet and I
were staying
at the Four Seasons,
and Kate said,
"Oh, the minibar. You can take
everything out of it.
And they just put it in
the next day."
And I was like, "Oh, my gosh."
So every day we were
clearing out the minibar
and just filling up
our suitcases
and being like,
"More stuff comes."
-Oh, my God!
-And we were just lying
on the bed just watching,
like, the first ten minutes
of every movie just like,
"No, not that one."
And then we got a call
from Miramax,
from the company
distributing the film,
saying, "This is
the worst room-service bill."
-"You guys got to slow down."
-Yeah. They were like,
"What's going on in there?"
We're like, "Oh, gosh. Sorry."
Like, just clearing the minibar.
-First getting a minibar,
you're just like,
"What is this?
This is the most insane thing."
-I know. I couldn't believe It.
It was like magic.
-Yeah, it is magic.
I was like,
"They just bring more?"
She was like, "Yes."
-My first time
staying at a hotel,
I remember, like, freaking out
of how many rolls
of toilet paper they had, too.
I'm like, "Spare rolls of
toilet -- This is unbelievable!"
-I know.
-Like, I just freaked out.
Yeah. A minibar. You're like,
"This is -- I'm in paradise."
After that, is that when you
worked with Drew Barrymore?
-Yes. Yeah. My next movie
was with Drew Barrymore.
-"Ever After."
-Angel. Yes. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How great is -- I know we --
everyone loves Drew Barrymore,
but, really, don't you just love
Drew Barrymore?
-Oh, she's just, like,
the most special,
the kindest person.
I had this moment.
She gave me a gift when
we started doing "Ever After."
And it was so sweet.
And I was like,
"I want to get her a gift."
And I found,
at this antique market,
these plates with a butterfly
opening in different stages.
I was like, "Perfect."
And I gave them to her,
and she was like,
[as Barrymore] "Oh, my God!
If each one of these plates
was to fall to the floor
and smash into
a thousand million pieces,
each one of the pieces
would scream,
'I love you, Melanie.'"
[ Laughter ]
Like --
-Oh, my gosh.
-In the moment.
-That is unbelievable!
-I'm so nervous.
I'm so nervous.
It wasn't a very good
impression,
but just the moment...
-Unbelievable impression.
That is exactly Drew,
by the way. That is her.
-But, like, in the moment
of receiving the gift,
that's what came
out of her mouth.
It was the most beautiful,
poetic, like...
I just was like,
"Oh, you're a fairy.
You're like a living..."
-She really is a fairy.
She's a living --
Yeah, she's unbelievable.
-Amazing person.
-Before we get into
"Yellowjackets,"
which frightens me, scares me --
-I'm sorry.
-Yeah. It's the most frightening
thing I've ever seen in my life.
-Yeah.
-It's a brilliant story.
But I want to get to that.
But also, speaking of scary,
"The Last of Us."
You were fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Last of Us."
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're great.
-Thank you. Thank you.
She's a horrible person.
-Yeah, it's interesting how
you're playing these roles.
You're such a nice person,
but, yeah.
-Something needs to come out,
apparently.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Your husband, Jason Ritter,
who is very talented
and funny and nice.
He is actually --
You said he's in episode --
or one of the episodes
of "Last of Us."
-He's in episode five, yeah.
-And I go -- I didn't see him.
I don't remember.
Because I love him.
I'm a fan. And I go,
"I don't remember him."
And you go, "Yeah.
He was one of the..."
-He was a stunt person.
He trained
with the stunt people,
and he just did
all these amazing stunts.
It's, like, his lifelong dream.
He got put in the makeup,
and he came out of the ground
and was falling over
and doing all these --
I shot him once.
-You shot him once?
-Yeah.
-Why not? Yeah. Of course.
-Why not?
-Here's a picture
of you two backstage
in "The Last of Us" there.
[ Audience awws ]
He looks great.
[ Laughs ]
-So romantic.
-It's so romantic.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I want to talk
about "Yellowjackets."
Because here we go.
This is season two.
And, honestly, I thought the
premise was just so brilliant.
I'm still guessing. I still
don't know what's going on.
[ Laughter ]
Really.
-I don't either, by the way.
You know?
-How do we describe the show,
just the basic story line?
-Well, the basic story line,
there's a plane crash
in the '90s in the wilderness.
A group of teenage female
soccer players are stranded.
They're forced to do
terrible things to survive.
And then the other half
of the story
takes place in the present day
with --
It follows four,
now this season, six
of the survivors
of the plane crash.
-And no one really knows
what happened
when they were stranded.
-Yeah.
-And that story starts
to come out, and it is bonkers.
-It is bonkers. Yeah.
-It is so unbelievable.
Everyone's great in it,
but, gosh, you were so good.
And season two --
-There were moments, like --
I would get a script and read
what they were having someone do
and just text, like,
Sophie Nélisse,
who plays little me.
I was like,
"Are you going to be okay?
-Oh, my God.
-Will you be okay?"
She was like,
"I think I can do it."
She's so talented.
She's so amazing.
I mean, I love all of them.
-It's well done.
Everybody is so great.
It is a must-watch
if you haven't seen it.
Congrats on all the awards
that you've received for this
and been nominated for it.
Well, well, well deserved.
-Thank you.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Melanie Lynskey in
season two of "Yellowjackets."
Take a look.
-Miss Sadecki,
do you understand your rights
as I have explained them to you?
-Yes, I -- I do.
-Why did you kill Adam Martin?
-What? I -- I didn't.
-Didn't what?
-I didn't murder
Adam -- whoever.
I -- I didn't murder anyone.
-I never said he was murdered.
-But -- But you said
someone killed him.
-So how was the sex?
Mind-blowing or just, like,
really, really hot?
-They're definitely
not going to ask me that.
-Oh. So he couldn't
get it up, huh?
Is that why you murdered him?
-Okay.
So I think we're done here.
-Yeah, I think we're done here.
Melanie Lynskey, everybody.
Season two of "Yellowjackets"
premieres March 24th
on Showtime.
We're talking De La Soul
after the break. Come on back.